hey guys Ryan right here so a lot of
people have actually been requesting
that I check out other YouTube videos
and this got me really interested
because I realized that or the past like
month and a half to maybe two months
maybe like five actually I actually
haven't been keeping up to date with
what's going on on YouTube viral videos
and stuff like sure there's like certain
channels I follow but as far as like
what's really trending on YouTube what's
popular I haven't been checking them out
so I wanted to you know just go through
like popular on YouTube channel whatever
that channels go up and then just look
at some of the most popular videos going
on and I know some of them are I've been
requested so it's about time I checked
this [ __ ] out so the first thing I'm
going to check out his thing called
respect re to PE CT I don't know
anyway let's watch this
Jerrica
hot dogs
we gotta get that hat now
so what happens at baseball games
respect
ha
haha
it's all gonna wanna do now with my hat
yeah J sorry
oh yeah Jordan
that was a pretty cool commercial man
you know like at first I was just
laughing cuz it was like is that what
happens at baseball games and everyone
just tilt their hat up I would love if
that's what happens in real life that
everyone at the stadium tilts their hats
up and then it starts going all around
New York City everyone just like mm-hmm
and then he finally placed the [ __ ]
baseball game that would be really
[ __ ] cool that made me feel like you
know one man respect you know it's like
the peace sign this is the new peace
sign the little tilt of the hat up
anyway guys yeah a few of you actually
recommended I check that video out so
thank you if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe if you subscribe here
in some mad respect subscribe I wanna do
some shout outs here meet Claudio it's a
girl hey what's up baby
hey Ryan [ __ ] you whoa this took a
different route give me a shout-out and
stop being mean to Marie she's a sweet
girl so back off love your channel
though hey I'm a little bit mean to
Marie but Marie knows it come on it goes
back to those you know elementary days
and mean to the girl because I like her
cuz I want to bang her my penis to be
inside of her and one day will happen
cuz I'll do it so no marine just freaked
me out Amy hey Claudio um you wanted to
shout out well baby how you doing I like
your hair it's purple I like purple I
want you to twist my titties and give me
a purple nurple Dark Lord double x69
like the last two digits a lot
sixty-nine one of my favorite positions
nothing's just better than when you get
to eat out of vagina and then you get
your dick sucked at the same time just
how [ __ ] cool is that respect you
guys are [ __ ] awesome
can I get a shout-out please well dark
Laura double X 69 you must be referring
to your black penis mean the Dark Lord
double X that's pretty large penis 69
that's what you like to do well my
friend this is your shoutout you get as
many 69s as possible and I want you to
tell me your secret to getting it done
what's annoying is a girl who loves
and out but doesn't like giving [ __ ]
I like eating you know I like dining out
to I like to dine and then eat around
sometimes I'm too cool it doesn't feel
good
Reuben DeLaGarza hey Ryan can I get a
shout out I promise to be satisfied all
night long haha just kidding PS tell
Murray for me that I said what up girl a
lot of people really like you more
really get it what's so special about it
Reuben DeLaGarza you my friend are a
good subscriber you subscribed well when
you click that button I knew we had a
special connection so thank you you and
I are beautiful you're beautiful you're
beautiful you're beautiful it's true and
then when we break up did i disappoint
you or let you down should I be feeling
guilty or let the judges frown goodbye
my lover
bye my friend I hope I never have to
sing that song to you cuz that's my
wedding song to Murray